you know MARY POPPINS spends a lot of
time talking about how great
supercalifragilistic expialidocious is
but really down plays its critical role
as a pickup tool in the movie one of the
characters specifically says why not
i shouldn'ta me girl and now me girls me
wife get on it all your tender rights
forget your instagrammy photos and
talking about your favorite place to eat
avocado toast it is all about plastering
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious all
over your profile that stuff is dating
boy
[Applause]
[Music]
hello internet welcome to chim chiminey
chim chiminey film film theory we
analyze movies to the IIST degree that's
right friends the remake of Mary Poppins
is out now and it's given lin-manuel
Miranda it's some new tracks for their
Spotify playlist and in honor of the
punchy new Mary Poppins remix today
we're taking a look back at the original
Mary Poppins back from 1964 yeah it is
really that old on a personal note I
just finished watching every Disney
movie from the Disney deaths trilogy
we're in the middle of and let me tell
you I'm not everything in that Disney
Vault stays fresh forever make my music
song of the south boy those have not
aged well I think it's safe to say that
Mary Poppins is just one of those
timeless movies that holds up from 1964
to the time four-year-old matpat dance
step in time around my house and my
underwear
thought I was a chimney sweep it was
awesome it was definitely four year old
matpat and definitely not 14 year old
mat path by 14 I put on a shirt anyway
as much as this movie is one of my
favorites of all time there is one thing
that's always made me wonder who was
right about the tuppence now in case
you've forgotten the plot of Mary
Poppins and by proxy your soul let me
refresh you so you know what I'm talking
about mr. banks
the stodgy banker and mrs. banks the
airheaded suffragette have Jane and
Michael they're two adorable children
and daughter Bo well that's debatable I
must say their musical nanny Mary
Poppins takes them on world win
adventures and teaches them life lessons
like making sure you step on other
people's chalk drawings without paying
them and treating medicine like candy
one day in a totally passive aggressive
move against their father for almost
firing her she sends the children to the
bank with him and uses psychological
manipulation to convince Michael that he
should donate his two pens or tuppence
to a beggar woman who sells birdseed
what a nothing to say
to people's heads his father warns him
about pigeon disease or something and
instead twists his arm to do the
responsible thing and invest his toughen
in the bank so that it games compound
interest yeah try explaining that one to
a five-year-old when they get to the
bank a bunch of really intense bankers
grab his change in Michael yells which
spooks other patrons in the bank to
start asking for their money this
tuppence causes a run on the entire bank
which results in mr. banks getting fired
and ultimately having a crisis of
conscience in the end banks comes to his
senses and uses the tuppence to buy a
kite and fly it with his son everyone
goes to the park for the most
unbelievable scene in the entire movie
we're like fifty people are all flying
kites at the same time and none of them
are getting their strings tangled up
TLDR miss tuppence plays a massive role
movie and apparently on the entire
banking system of Great Britain so given
the incredible importance of these two
pennies I can't help but ask did Michael
make the right call after all the
bankers might be boring in a little bit
handsy they do make a valid point you
can invest your money rather than buying
birdseed so you can be rich and happy
later all while contributing to the
major world industrialization like wow I
mean two cents don't buy what it used to
I guess you don't have to be Einstein to
figure out that compound interest can be
a powerful force even the quote the most
powerful force in the universe is
compound interest is frequently
attributed to Albert Einstein but as
boring as investing might be it seems to
have worked well for the bankers so who
was right what should Michael have done
with the tuppence
given that Mary Poppins has set over a
hundred years ago back in the year 1910
its grand to be an Englishman in 1910
King Edward's on the throne it's the age
of men we have a huge runway to actually
accumulate interest so we really get to
see how this plays out and determine
whether Michael should have trusted in
the bank and what that tuppence would
actually be worth today and the results
are surprising figuring out the answer
to this seems like it should be simple
you just perform some basic interest
calculations but to Penny's way back
then turns out to be a lot more
complicated than you'd first think in
1910 Britain had a ridiculously complex
money system involving words that sounds
silly to modern us viewers things like
fallings and shillings like fairytale
money writes well not back in 1910 when
one pence was actually worth one two
hundred and fortieth of a pound which
would be like us having some coin that
was worth a few tenths of a penny the
long story short this system of currency
is silly but we gotta use it if we're
gonna get ourselves an accurate
calculation luckily in 1971 Britain's
shifted over to a base-10 system like we
have today probably because no one in
the world could figure out how much a
candy bar cost over there so Michaels
tuppence is actually worth point zero
eight three three three three three
three repeating pounds which is a little
over 11 cents in today's terms so that's
gonna be our starting number in 1910 the
British interest rate on a normal
savings account was three point five
percent which by today's standards is
great but it turns out to not be all
that helpful for Michael at 3.5%
interest Michaels deposit will earn him
a whopping point five six farthings
which again is a meaningless number but
suffice it to say it is really really
small
the farthing is 1/4 of a pence or penny
to our interchangeable the name actually
comes from four thing the pence is
fourth hence the name are they anyway
the farthing was the smallest unit of
currency in Britain so Michael earned
less than one of the smallest form of
currency Britain had at the time and so
what do you think the bank does when you
earn less than one of its smallest
currency in the year that you have to
earn it well they round down and when
you stop and think about it that
actually
make sense if they didn't they would in
essence be creating new money out of
thin air and giving it away if they were
to round those partial cents up so poor
my gold who didn't read the fine print
when he invested actually earns zero
interest in his first year okay that's
one year out of a hundred and eight
years except that's exactly what happens
every single year over and over and over
again where the interest rate never gets
high enough for Michael to even earn a
single farthing in short as insane as it
sounds Michael's balance never grows
larger than tuppence never two pennies
for a hundred and eight years that's the
thing about compound interest it only
works if your interest each year is
gonna be greater than zero at the end of
this analysis I feel bad for the guy the
buzz nobody that's all you wanted to do
so I decided to test out some more
optimistic scenarios to see if we could
at least get him any return out of this
deal let's say that there was a way for
him to earn some interest like if his
tuppence were part of a bigger bank
accounts how much would his tuppence
earn if there was no rounding can it
just accrued interest slowly again using
Britain's incredibly well documented
historical interest rates we can
calculate all this out from 1910 to 2018
and come up with Michaels new hundred
year old two pounds and 11 pence two
dollars and seventy cents for all the
Americans in the audience doesn't look
like Michaels gonna be taking you on any
shopping sprees to Harrods anytime soon
but on the bright side Michaels
great-grandson can buy himself a bloke
Coke and a bag of Maltesers from the
Tesco so at this point I was like I
guess the lesson here is that banks will
rip off your tuppence and Michael would
definitely have been better off buying
birdseed rather than holding out over a
century to buy a Jaffa Cake in a bottle
of water it seems like this was clearly
a scam but there is one last avenue to
explore here the wide world of
investments when we get to the bank I
shall show you what may be done with the
vault happens and I think you'll find it
extremely interesting as the bank says
Michaels money could be part of global
initiatives like majestic
self-advertising canal whatever the heck
those are Michael certainly
no.5 mr. Dawes the bank's ancient
founder extols Michael on the virtues of
all kinds of ventures like foreclosures
dividends shares and debtor sales some
of these actually being really risky
investments but hey this is in 1910
England's financial markets are soaring
London is the economic capital of the
world the UK has a 3 percent
unemployment rate it seems like a great
time to invest and it was until 1914
when a little something you might have
heard of happened world war wand when
the Great War or World War 1 set in much
of the private industry fueling
Britain's financial dominus ground to a
screeching halt as a huge portion of
resources were reallocated to
manufacturing munitions and all the
other things that it takes to run a war
the specific industries that mr. Dawes
mentions in the song shipyards the
mercantile tanneries and Kohli Ares
which I had to look up in our apparently
coal miners reallocated funds and
manpower to build for the war effort
all while losing their top men to be
sent into trenches across Europe but the
British people were no dumb crumpets
during this time they sense that all
this war was destabilizing the economy
and they did what everyone else does
when they feel insecure about their
finances they took all their money and
they stuffed it into mattresses they
began to withdraw money from the banks
which in turn led to fears that there
would be a bank run if everyone saw the
economy and declined and then rushed to
withdraw their money there literally
wouldn't be enough banknotes in the
country for everyone to have all their
money back in cash in response the
British Treasury began to print more
cash at a rate of 5 million new
banknotes a day this is a common thing
to do in more times and if you want to
see how it usually goes you can check
out this game theory episode will
recover exactly that but I'm gonna spoil
it for you it never ends well when you
start literally printing money and
injecting it into the economy any
economist can tell you what happens
inflation every new banknote that gets
printed effectively D values all the
money that currently exists it's the
reason that the government can't just
solve its debt problems by printing more
money and so what does
I mean for Michael well it means during
the war instead of his investment
growing his tuppence is actually losing
value and by proxy buying power the
whole time
fortunately there was still one
investment opportunity available war
bonds at the time this would seem like a
good financial move war bonds had an
interest rate of 5% several points
higher than the market interest rates of
time and banks and citizens alike
weren't encouraged to buy war bonds as a
part of doing their patriotic duty they
were also considered safe because they
were backed by the British Treasury
rather than a business that can go under
so bonds are considered one of the
lowest risk investments that you can
possibly make fun fact by the way it's
the same reason that China is really
gung-ho about buying US Treasury bonds
these days they're the most reliable
investment that you can buy so we have
ourself a safe investment with a high
interest rate almost supporting the war
effort buying war bonds seems like a
win-win for everyone involved and even
seems to align with mr. dawes's strategy
for investing all the bank money so how
does this last-ditch effort to make any
sort of money out of Michaels toughens
work out unfortunately yet another tough
lesson in history for all my banks a
decade after the war in 1929 the world
gets hit with the Great Depression
remember all those war bonds that got
that fantastic five percent interest
rate well the government didn't pay
those back yet in 1932 Chancellor
Neville Chamberlain called for investors
to do their patriotic duty yet again
only this time accept a 3.5 percent
return instead with the overwhelming
majority of war bonds just changing over
to that new rate i am altering the deal
pray I don't alter it any further Darth
Vader might not have changed his deals
again but Neville Chamberlain absolutely
did a British government converted the
war bonds from bonds into what's known
as perpetual perpetual z' that give the
government the right to not pay back the
loans if they so chose what once was a
very safe investment with a solid
interest rate that helps support the war
effort then became an IOU that you can
either choose to pay back or not to pay
back guess which one the British
government chose surprise surprise
surprise no effort has been
ADEs since the 1930s to repay any of
those war bonds it's believed that about
a hundred and twenty-five thousand
people are still holding on to their
bonds some of whom might have inherited
them from parents or grandparents who
bought them during World War one still
nothing paid out borrow money from
people to pay for the war and then just
decide afterward that you're not gonna
pay it back that sounds like a great
deal for the British government and not
such a great deal for Michael in his
investment portfolio the worst trade
deal maybe ever shined anywhere but
definitely a pretty bad deal except
maybe for that time when Neville
Chamberlain said hey Adolf will totally
let you take over Czechoslovakia if you
promise not to attack us once you're
done taking over the rest of Europe yeah
we're talking about that Neville
Chamberlain made a lot of bad calls
so clearly Michael Dodds deployed by
hanging on to that tuppence but how
about where it really ends up buying
kite fixing materials was that the right
choice as it turns out in what I'm sure
was a complete accident on the part of
Disney it absolutely was with tuppence
for paper and strings you can have your
own set aways mr. banks was able to
purchase both paper and string for
tuppence in the movie were asked to buy
those items today would cost you between
five and ten British pounds depending on
the specific paper and string you're
buying and yeah I know that sounds
expensive but there was literally a
paragraph in an earlier version of the
script dedicated to pricing out the
grades of string and paper so just be
glad that I cut it down to the chase
with this one even in our best case
scenario there was no way Michael would
have been able to buy kite making
materials in 2018 with the money from
that tuppence so in short after a long
harrowing journey to get here yes
Michael you made the right choice to
spend your tuppence in 1910 and it turns
out that flying your kite with your dad
isn't just a cathartic family moment but
also a sound financial decision but hey
that's just a theory a film theory and
seriously this new Mary Poppins movies
better be good because my entire
childhood is on the line this is not a
joke I'm warning you Lynn Burt has been
my hero for years if you're cockney
accent is not as bad as dick Van Dyke's
I will be sorely
appointed
[Music]